welcome back to las vegas now if you're
looking for a unique summer adventure
the nevada northern railway
is now offering a unique train ride
experience this one involves sunsets
stars champagne and vintage vibes sounds
like my kind of ride
all right let's welcome president of nnr
mark bassett to show us
more to tell us more hey mark
hi thank you for having me oh please it
is our pleasure i'm so excited to share
this experience with everyone and let
them know how they can get involved so
just describe the train
and what it includes
the train ride we board at 7 30
and we head into the mountains and you
get to watch
the sun go down and we have some of the
most beautiful sunsets here
and then after the sun goes down the
stars
pop out we serve you a glass of
champagne
on our antique train and we have an
astronom
astronomy interpreter on board who will
point down some highlights of the heaven
oh yeah and it's educational too i
didn't know that
yep it's just a a really relaxed
slow trip in fact when you visit the
nevada northern railway we tell you to
set your watch back a century
oh i love that and how far are we
traveling how how long is the ride
uh the train ride is about three hours
we leave at 7 30 we come back about
10 30 but it's really slow and easy
going
okay and you have to tell us i hear you
you said you had astronomers on board
tell us why the stars and the skies are
so special in this location
talk about the location well
we are just an hour away from great
basin national park and great basin
national park is an international dark
sky
park our skies are still dark you can
see the heavens
the milky way and it's just really
amazing we take it for granted because
we see it every night but
you don't have that option right but
there's nothing like the nevada skies i
have to admit the sunsets and sunrises
here are incredible
but to top all of that off you said
champagne is included with the fair
so you get a glass of bubbly too that's
wonderful so how do we get tickets and
how can we how can we ride
you can ride we are four hours north of
las vegas on u.s 93
and we're also 20 degrees cooler so
that's the biggest place too
and yes and tickets are available on our
website
which is n n r y
dot com all right thank you so much mark
we appreciate you joining us
you're very welcome thank you for having
us have a great day you too cheers